nessa what's going on how can i help um
i had a baby last year
in july and my husband and i decided
that we were going to kind of follow cdc
guidelines and do everything that we
could
to keep our new baby safe during a
pandemic
okay and it caused a lot of
uh tension on his side of the family and
it started out with passive aggressive
comments and then
all the way up to his dad messaging him
uh saying bad things about me and
um now they are trying to manipulate and
gaslight the situation
um and say things like they're not you
know they'll just wait and see his
their great their grandson by the time
he's 21 and things like
that hey hey listen
because they're not my family when
adults act like
four-year-olds and throw four-year-old
temper tantrums i love it
now if this was happening at my house it
would not be funny so i'm i am
i'm laughing at you not with you
right but no no no i get it i need you
to know oh gosh
so you do anyway
so how can i help man how can i
i'm basically you know this this
these conversations now like my
relationship is with them is
extremely strained i tried to sit down
with them and have a face to face about
why these things are hurting me and how
it's not personal and like this is
literally just about the safety of our
baby
and it's just gotten worse um and so i'm
just wondering
how how do i move on and like
be okay with that myself and
at least like be okay enough to help
them
continue to try to have a relationship
with their grandbaby
man you're not this is so frustrating
man
this is i cannot stand it
when grown-ups act like children and i
cannot stand it
not even out of some trauma right just
because
we aren't getting our way right so if a
grown-up
throws a fit and they've got some stuff
from their past they're working through
some heavy stuff in their life i get it
man that happens
but when grown-ups just throw like a
like a this is a
my five-year-old doesn't throw these
fits anymore
and then they leave you the the new
person into the family
the mother of a small child trying to
figure out how you can best heal the
situation
a mess you didn't create ah jeez
okay so a couple of questions how how is
your husband navigating this
sure so uh when the messages came
through
by the way good good good job grown-ups
i'm gonna i'm gonna text these really
hard things
because i'm so grown up i won't even
call you and say them to your face i'm
gonna
send them in a text message that'll that
way to go everybody all right continue
so uh he called his dad immediately and
was just like
this is completely out of line because
your husband's a
grown-up good job excellent he's like we
make
all of these decisions together this is
my son
i am his father like i'm doing the best
that i can and we're both new parents
this is our first kid too
dude look at your husband man way to go
yeah so it's the first time that he's
kind of stood up to his parents and kind
of drawn that line
yeah and um so he's handling it like
like a champ he's he's doing amazing um
and
it sucks because now that now his
brother is
starting to get involved and calling him
and they had a big fight over the phone
about
all of this and stuff and so he's doing
the best that he can in this situation
and he's amazing
yeah man i hate that for y'all all right
so here's here's the reality of your
situation
number one i'm gonna flip this whole
thing around okay
sure this is the this could not have
been a better situation for you guys
and here's why you're dealing with two
immature
people and this was gonna come out
sooner rather than later
it was going to come out when your kid
was spending a week at their house
it was going to come out when they
didn't like the way you were
disciplining their their grandbaby right
as though that trumps your
um right like it was gonna come out and
it was gonna come out in a big and
bigger and bigger way
the difference now is the kid isn't
involved
right the kid is the proxy for this
power struggle
but there's not a five-year-old or a
nine-year-old or a 13 year old
downloading
their insights into how poor your
parenting is right
so where i'm telling you this is the
best thing that could have happened is
you got to let two people you have to
see their true colors
and now you get to build really firm
strong boundaries
this is in a weird way brought you and
your husband closer because you got to
watch him stand up for that
that that lady he loves right and you
always wondered if he would he did
right and he stood up to his parents
into his mama that's hard man
into his super aggressive texting father
it's so ridiculous um so good for both
of you
now the reality this sucks right this is
not good this is not how you drew it up
of course you didn't want to have a baby
in the middle of a global pandemic of
course you didn't want to have a baby
when you couldn't leave and go spend
time with your friends and family
of course you had these visions and
dreams of grandparents coming in and
being involved and all that's a mess
and then on top of that it's it's turned
silly
so what i'm going to tell you is this i
want you to
forget the relationship part you didn't
create that mess
you chose to respond to your baby in a
certain way and i want everyone to
listen to this
i'm not high-fiving her decision i
could care less what she chose to do the
reality is she
chose you and your husband chose
i'll call your husband bill how about
that nessa so nessa and
bill decided we have a new baby
these are the boundaries around our baby
and
bill's parents threw a temper tantrum it
doesn't matter what they
are i've had friends who are like hey
before you walk into my home you have to
do 30 push-ups and wash your hands and
get a colonic and all the
like dude i just want to hang up and
i've had other parents who will just
hand me your kid while i'm mowing the
yard and be like hey here you go
man so every parent's different doesn't
matter they get to set the boundaries
because it's their kid
and so what i want you guys to do is
this you guys have now
seen a world where grandparents are
going to act like children here's the
deal they're going to come around okay
they just are and i want you guys to not
lose your
dignity don't lose your character don't
lose who you are
in order to make that work because
that's never gonna work
right so you all get to decide
you get to decide who you're going to be
what kind of boundaries you're going to
have
and you're going to have to create a new
universe that doesn't include his
parents for a while until they choose to
grow up
and interact with their grandkids on
their terms and if brother wants to jump
in the mix
bro you're hurting mom's feelings
because but cool
then he gets to decide what he you know
he's making he's
he's crossing whatever line he wants to
cross right and all you're doing is
you guys drew boundaries and obviously a
boundary-free family
right and then people are gonna run up
and hit their head on those boundaries
and see if they hold
and now you guys just get to hold them
and it's lonely and isolating and
frustrating and annoying and you're
gonna weep and you're going to be sad
and you're going to wonder what am i
doing wrong
what you're doing wrong is you're
deciding what kind of parent you want to
be and you're sticking to it
i can't tell you anything magic that's
going to make them not immature
and i can't make anything tell you
anything magic that's going to make you
less frustrated at how they're
responding
you know what i mean i hate that for
y'all yeah no absolutely
not like i get it i get it so is there a
season where
um like let's say
in your immediate community the
restrictions are lifted your your
husband gets a text bill gets a text
here in a few weeks and says hey we both
got vaccinated we're both good
um we'd love to come see your grandkid
are you
poisoned now to that relationship where
you don't want him around or
no are you gonna are you gonna welcome
them in
yeah no i have always welcome to welcome
them in i've always been the one to send
them the resources to invite them to
facetime call to do whatever they can to
connect with them
that's always coming from like me
mostly and so absolutely please come in
um i've i've kind of built up this
compartment
compartmentalization almost to where
their relationship with
our son is completely separate from
their relationship with me
and i try to get them involved in the
new milestones that he's
you know doing and you know i'm
extremely
the same like nice and kind and
you know all of that interaction's the
same so absolutely
um so you gotta know nessa this is gonna
start over time to put a strain on your
marriage and i want you all to be
upfront and honest with each other
throughout this process okay
right yeah we made an appointment for
marriage counseling to kind of come up
with a game plan on
how to navigate this moving forward
awesome um
yeah awesome and that's in the work
when you feel that first shard
that first little splinter of resentment
against your husband
because there's gonna come a moment when
he's just gonna say hey can we just let
him come by
right and can we like is there another
thing we can can we meet him halfway if
they all wear masks and they'll
like is there that's happened it's
already happened right okay so
when you start to see him changing
sides on you that's probably not
happening he's trying to find a middle
ground he may have met with a doctor he
may have and somebody said hey it's okay
for grandparents to hug your baby it's
okay
and and all that as you go through that
make sure when you start to feel like
he's switching teams on you
make sure you stop and pause and not in
an accusing way not now let's go to war
against u2 way but
say hey man i feel like we're switching
sides here is there something
you want to talk about tell me where
this is coming from right
and it's probably him doing the best he
can to not lose both his mom and dad
and his wife at the same time right
right and that's hard
and you i want you to commit to where
you feel like you can it sounds like you
are being
you've got really firm boundaries and
you're really you don't want those to
sever a relationship right you want
people to respect who you are and where
you are
which i think is great um i also want
you to always make sure you are checking
those boundaries
are they are they appropriate are they
right get somebody in your life i love
y'all going to see a marriage counselor
make sure those boundaries don't become
brick walls right if they become brick
walls and you end up walling yourself in
as much as you all other people out
and so make sure those boundaries when
they're drawn around medical issues or
beliefs not values but
they're drawn around beliefs man there's
some flexibility because at some point
you may read a new book you may
have your doctor may meet with your
child and they may say nah you're good
man
you're good to let them hug whatever
those things are so make sure
that you are able to remain
peaceful and flexible but at the same
time
i'm proud of you for standing strong i'm
proud of you all for working hard on
this together and i'm proud of you all
for saying ah we see a forest fire in
the future
let's head down this road and go meet
with a marriage counselor good
for you parents
when you have grandkids they are their
kids
first and then yours and i know you've
been waiting for this moment for so so
so so long
i know that you fill in the blank
they're not your kids they're not
and you remember back when people took
advantage of you and frustrated you and
said why you let them wear that why you
let them look like that and you know
it's annoying don't repeat that
i tell you what man i won the lottery
when it came to parents
and how they respect me and my wife
our boundaries with our kids it's
incredible and i know i'm really
fortunate and privileged with that
because not everyone gets that so
thank you for that call nessa let me
know how that uh marriage counseling
session goes i'd love you to reach back
out and let me know how that goes y'all
working together to come up with a game
plan moving forward
and i'm grateful for the call